welcome to film courage this is episode
164 I'm Karen warden and I'm David brand
you can find our archives on iTunes as
well as film Curren com our guest today
is an Renton director of the perfect
family starring Kathleen Turner Emily
Deschanel Jason Ritter Richard
Chamberlain and more and a perfect
family premiered at the 2011 tribeca
film festival that's right in a whole
slew of other festivals as well the
perfect family is about suburban super
mom Eileen Cleary on played by Academy
Award nominee Kathleen Turner who is the
ultimate Catholic and and she she's been
nominated for the Catholic women of the
year at her local parish and it looks
like she's about to get the plaque to
prove it okay only the final test
remains and introducing her family to
the church board for the seal of
approval right and in terms of her
family she must finally face the truth
about her nonconformist family a truth
that she's been glossing over four years
her gay daughter Shannon played by emily
deschanel is about to marry her life
partner and then her unhappily married
son Frank jr. played by Jason Ritter is
having an affair with local manicurist
sounds interesting and Eileen's own
marriage to a recovered alcoholic is
pulling at the seams so let's find out
more about it please like a man retin I
am huh Waka man you know what to be on
the show oh oh we're super excited to
have you and we want to talk a little
bit about your life right now the
perfect family is now released
everywhere it's in it's the a triple run
right now and people all over the world
are watching this film and they're
commenting and they're reaching out to
you and you're traveling everywhere tell
us a little bit about your life right
now how do you feel well I'm excited I
feel like our team's done a really great
job of getting the film out there
we are basically only in North America
right now we're playing at some
international film festivals but you
know in theaters it's a small release
we've played probably and look just over
20 20 cities and we're also did video on
demand at the same time so you know we
were sort of factoring that into the
whole overall plan for the film um but
yeah it's all it's all moving and I'm
proud of how far the film's been able to
get out and we are you know reaching
internationally at least with people on
Facebook and things like that commenting
and asking us when the films coming to
their country so that's fun um that yeah
and you know I mean how how long has it
been since there's like like at what
point because the film the film release
may fourth and you know we we had a
chance to meet you in person in October
at the filmmaker forum like at what
point did life really started to get
crazy for you I mean was it was it right
at the release of the film or was like
how far in advance that all of a sudden
has been like the storm or we're taking
you well I actually do it was before we
started shooting because I mean you know
what it's like going into production
it's just so full on and you know i was
working another job at the same time
then and so sort of negotiating that and
you know there's sort of been more
busier periods and slower periods
throughout but definitely once we we
decided that we were going to distribute
this film and really push it out there
which was actually around October last
year maybe a little bit before but
October was when we really started
putting the team together of who we
wanted to work with um but you know just
sort of it was like Kip went from there
Wow interesting well now you have a
wonderful background in that you have a
degree is it in physiotherapy from
Sydney University that's right we just
physical therapy here good I'll choke a
slightly different name there but yeah
so I did this is science degree and
learn all about the body and you know
the muscles and the musculoskeletal
system etc but I went from from
02 kind of feeling like there was so
much more to the body than just the the
joints and the muscles and the structure
which you know in a straight degree you
don't learn any more than that so I went
on in sort of studied massage and then
started studying energy and really
learning how the emotions started you
know having an effect on the body and it
was sort of through that process I
started studying at a healing school
which is why I came to the states to go
to the school here and part of that
school was really worked with creativity
and how creativity really moves energy
in the body and can you know open just
open parts of yourself that when that
that that part of you is shut down its
just as kind of limiting how you are in
the world and so through through my
studies there I realized that I'd always
wanted to study acting and had done a
little bit in school but it was never
something that I thought you know you
could go into as a profession at the
time so when I was me I was in New York
when I was studying at the school and so
I started studying acting in New York
and that's sort of what started my path
along into the filmmaking world okay in
how long did you do that for and you
also did voiceover work too right yes
doing everything and studying acting in
voiceover doing some voice over stuff at
the same time I probably started it for
like five years I just started it with
like private you know private schools in
New York part time and um but what I
realized in doing that is you know as an
actor what I loved i really love script
analysis and I really loved
understanding character from you know
more the background point of view and
and felt like as an actor I was sort of
only going out for these parts that I
didn't frankly really care about and I
wanted to you know be able to be a
little bit more in control of the
stories and the things that I was doing
and you know I certainly as an actor I
never got to a level where I was a you
know a working actor that I could do
that full time but um but I you know I
don't know I really felt like all the
way I was being pushed more towards
directing and then you know in New York
I kind of realized oh if I want to be
directing later I probably need to start
now so that this was about five or six
years ago I think yeah
it's like that so from those experiences
being in front of the camera and also
doing voiceover work what did that teach
you once you got behind the camera and
then you were directing you know actors
and people that were you know very
invested in what you thought of their
performance well wow that's a big
question um I I learned an incredible
amount um I think you know as a director
that background the thing that's most
helpful is it made me feel comfortable
with actors and made me feel like I have
a sense of how to work how to work with
them and also how to recognize the
different people need different things
from the director different actors need
different things and they work in
different ways so I think that was an
important thing to be able to take into
directing that there's not just one way
to do it and and that's really important
to be aware of with the actors I find
that fascinating can you just give a
sort of a prototype of what one actor
needs versus what the other one does one
need more sort of an emotional or sort
of validation whereas others might need
more of a just concrete instruction
definitely definitely I mean I feel like
some actors might prefer to you know
talk about the material good really
understand what you're going for in the
material and then be able to go away and
work on that how they want to approach
that performance wise on their own and
some are really open to being in
rehearsal and working working it out in
rehearsal in the moment trying different
things you know really working what
maybe that even the beats could be in a
certain scene and then want to work more
with you so it just it depends and both
you know both have them their merits
because ultimately it's when you get on
sad you don't haven't we do we hang on
we did a little bit of rehearsal just so
it's clear for this film we it was very
short rehearsal period but we did like
14 4 days um so because you know when
you get on set there's not really time
you have to kind of really know what
you're gone for you're not in the film
it's not time to be rehearsing on the
set
so yeah so I think you know my
background helped me through the
rehearsal process and then into how to
be on set as well I mean it's really
interesting hearing hearing just hearing
you describe some of this stuff in
because like I'm just visualizing you
like really liking to break things down
you know the process me just even going
even hear you talk a little bit about
physical therapy about about studying
the body so it's like it's kind of kind
of like you'd like to to see the
components you know like break it down
to like it like its purest form and then
sort of like build it back up on your
own is that does that go into your
artistic process as well I think so yeah
I like that I think I'm certainly always
exploring like how something could be
done or what is there a better way to do
this or you know that that kind of thing
and I definitely think this this film
for me was a very much collaborative
process because I'm very interested in
what other people's experiences and you
know frankly on a first film you you
want people who are more experienced in
you around you and having that kind of
process of breaking things down and
figuring out how it works in my mind and
then bringing in everyone else's kind of
thoughts and and then putting it back
together in a way that sort of
encompasses the whole absolutely and did
your background and with the healing
arts than that did that come into play
um death you know with with you as a
director yeah definitely I mean in so
many ways um I as part of that that
training I studied a lot of psychology
so get to understand like how different
people you know how they're set up I use
the word character character ology
because that's how we what we call it
but it's really looking at someone and
how they how they operate in the world
and what makes them feel safe if what
makes them feel threatened those kind of
things so as a director to be able to
work with like crew and also actors and
have this this a little bit more of a
sense I think of how potentially because
it's not always accurate but how people
are in the world and what is feel
supportive to them I think that was a
huge help now the con Film Festival open
this week
and so for 2012 as with the 2010
addition we there were no female
directed films in the competition and in
doing a little research in the 64 years
of the festival I believe one woman was
it Jane Campion hope I'm saying anyway
has been awarded the Palme d'Or what's
your take on this oh no pressure you
know there's that petition going around
which hopefully everyone listening has
signed because it's it's a little
shocking really to hear that news I mean
if this petition wasn't going around
that melissa is doing from women in
Hollywood I'm I may not have been so you
know seen it actually because the
petition came right into my inbox and
then I've been seeing it everywhere but
you know I think it's I think it's sad I
mean I think that there is a lot of
talented women directors and to not even
have one in a lineup it just seems to be
its can't even quite process it what do
you think um you know I have my own
feelings on in that I think it's
typically been a man's game and I think
maybe it's a little threatening to have
women sort of join the club and I'm sure
that's probably not the most popular
opinion but I think probably behind
closed doors a lot of women have that
opinion that it is something that's been
typically a man's world and to break
through and enter it you have to sort of
be part of the good old boy network even
though it's more of an indie club it's
not sort of the the prototype of the the
good ol boy network does that see how
that you think is oh absolutely and
interestingly enough it's a similar
thing in television directing too and
there are certain networks that are
supporting trying to get more diverse
voices I just actually got into this
program in arm disney-abc television
it's a directing program where you get
to shadow veteran directors on their TV
shows and I'm in it because I'm a woman
like women are considered a minority in
television also and so I think it's
great that organizations like you know
Disney ABC you're trying to support
these diverse voices but i think it's
it's it's hard because it you know and
in a film world it's like who is who is
trying to support those voices right
isn't what the DGA is what four percent
of the membership is women i'm not sure
if that's the right right down but yeah
it's very small yeah I it was great you
know we watched an interview with with
Kathleen Turner Emily Deschanel you know
talking about the film the filmmaking
process and they were asked you know
what was it like working with a female
director what was it like working with
in and they both had very very favorable
strong comments you know they kind of
said you know and kind of just came in
there was you know the no-nonsense she
kind of knew what she wanted and just
checked that set moving day after day
after day so it was great hearing um the
the actresses some get behind you and
support you in that manner thank you and
I mean I have to say working with
someone like Kathleen Turner she I mean
she's very into theatre and so the
theatre process you know I mean it's a
lot of rehearsal but then you get on
stage and you do it so she very much was
into just it was so just wanting to get
it done there wasn't any wasting time in
hair and makeup there wasn't any you
know as soon as she was ready she was
sitting on that set you know because she
knew if she was on set it would make the
crew move faster as well so you know we
had a really short shoot schedule was 19
days so there wasn't any time for it to
be any other way and I was so grateful
that it because you don't know going in
with someone how they're going to be on
a day to day basis and she was
incredible well in keeping with that and
I kathleen's character is a devoutly
religious woman and she's committed to
pleasing her church and keeping
everything looking perfect so to speak
um from the outside despite things being
quite the contrary in her own life can
you share some of the things that Eileen
it's Eileen Cleary that she's trying to
keep from her friends and neighbors in
the clergy oh absolutely I think he said
some of it at the beginning right when
we're talking about about the plot but
it's really you know her family and her
husband is a recovered alcoholic but
he's you know had quite the past
her son is has left his wife and he's
having an affair with the local
manicurist so she certainly doesn't want
anyone to know about that and her
daughter is a lesbian is about to get
married to her life partner and you know
although I think in the background
Islands probably had some kind of
awareness of something with her
daughters she's been in complete denial
so it's in the moment of the film where
the daughter actually you know has to
tell her mom what's going on and and
isn't going to stand for this denial
anymore hmm I'm wondering why do you
think this is such a universal theme in
so many people's lives I mean why are
committed are people so committed to
keeping everything looking perfect i
think even if they don't have a similar
family dynamic the way Eileen Cleary
does there there's a lot of this we all
do it no try to keep up with the Joneses
and and make everything sort of look
shiny and beautiful from the outside
what do you think that is another good
question I mean I think its inherent in
in how abhorred up we're bored up to
look good to be good to sort of you know
to show our best to the world and and
then there becomes this thing if it's
not the best it shouldn't be shown so
I'm not entirely sure why that why am i
that is in society but it certainly is
and definitely a lot of people who've
seen the film have responded in similar
ways sayings so much like my family or
this you know this is my brother's
family or you know whatever whoever it's
someone in their periphery it's not
their own family you know prior to this
feature film you have one short film
that's listed on IMDb at least and you
didn't write this film how did they--how
did this this story sort of come you
know end up on your desk and then once
it once it was pitched to you or once it
was presented to you or once you had it
is this is this a story or a script that
you had to fight for to be the director
on well I actually um had decided that I
wanted to do a film and was what i was
looking for scripts so i found this
online called ink tip have you heard of
ink tip yes yeah so anyway ink tip is a
site where you know writers post their
scripts and you have to I mean it took a
little bit for me to actually get on the
side because you know there's certain
levels of producers and people that they
want on the side but I managed to get on
the side and then they supported me to
put a call out to riders for what I was
looking for so I was kind of able to you
know give some very and they were very
general parameters because I you know I
was looking for a good story basically
but one then that we make it for me and
so I had a ton of scripts sent to me
actually synopsises were sent to me so
then I could read the synopsis and then
if it was a script that I wanted to read
I would just let the right and i would
love to read your script so um but you
know that was a little bit of a process
and I read you know I certainly read
some interesting script some was
stronger than others but when I read
this one I just you know that the whole
for the whole family dynamics and the
essence of the story just really spoke
to me and I felt like it would be a very
relatable story for people the script
when I originally read it was it had
been written like 10 years ago so it was
dated so it needed a lot of work but the
essence of the family and the you know
and their relationships stayed the same
so tell us more about that process so
you get the script you're like yes I'm
I'm interested in directing this and
getting behind this producing it what
was the back and forth and also what was
sort of the timeline on that when was
this happening um this was um I think it
was the end of two thousand seven when I
started talking to the riders probably
right at the end of the year and we
probably went back and forth for three
to four months so you know I had sent
her she wanted to see my work I mean she
really wanted to know that if she was
going to option it to someone even
though this was her first script that
would be optioned she had a few written
that she was shopping around she wanted
to know that it was going to get made so
so I sent her my shore and we had quite
a few phone conversations about it and
you know
my vision for the script and how I was
planning to get it made and you know I
think after that at that time she just
decided to go for it which was great and
the original writer her name's Claire
Riley and she was she just basically
said to me it's your baby now you can do
what you want with it so she gave me
full permission to bring on another
rider because mia we had these
discussions about the superscript been
dated and you know how i felt like it
needle where I felt like it needed work
and I wanted to bring on a writer who
was in LA so I could you know being sit
down one-on-one with them and really
really work on it like that so yeah so
then when she did that with the script
and said do what you want with it I mean
that was a huge huge thing as a Gabe
gave us permission to really do whatever
and how long did you work on it with a
new screenwriter how long with did that
development on you know I mean three to
four months arranging it and now how
much longer after the long friends a
long process we worked on it probably
for a year before I thought our
producers on board and then we still
were rewriting after that and it was
another almost another year before we
recast so it was it was you know 18
months 18 months to two years of working
with this script to get it were needed
to be and of course it's not full time
because everyone's doing different
things but it was it was a lot of work
we probably did so so i optioned it
probably at the beginning like a March
and I think when the November we did a
reading our first reading of the script
which of course only went to show
furthermore what wasn't working I'm
gonna showed what was working too but
then it's even more work after that
because like okay here's where it's you
know not working but yeah so it's quite
a long long process but everyone who's
making films gets that yeah well know
you were working another job to at the
time this was all going on how are you
balancing all that well I was teaching
unfortunately the teaching part was
part-time so I was teaching at the
healing school I studied at I ended up
teaching this is quite a few years and
so that was perfect and then you know
have us have had a small practice so I
was doing that as well so I wasn't
working like nine to five every day
another job and doing this I was sort of
balancing I was working as much as I
needed to to be able to take care of
life and then the rest of the time I
could focus on them film I see I want to
go back to the theme of the film in that
sort of trying to keep everything
looking perfect and you know there's so
much fascination border bordering on
sort of a love-hate relationship that
America has with reality stars and also
mainstream stars and we seem so invested
in their personal lives despite the fact
that it may be all manufactured I'm
wondering why do you think we're so
fascinated by this is the reason just
what did it your take on that that we're
so invested if you sometimes I'll just
read the YouTube comments or or the
comments on yahoo it won't even read the
article but people are so invested in
people that they don't even know what do
you think the reason is what's up that
so i don't i don't really i mean it's
out of my area of expertise to answer
that that's for sure but what do I think
um I have to say I think most things
that are put out there I'm very
fabricated so you know again it says
putting up appearances thing which is
going along with with this theme that
we're discussing but I think sometimes
it's easier to look outside of yourself
and focus on someone else and what
they're doing in the world it rather
than them being inside and really you
know having your own being in touch with
your own feelings and emotions and
looking at where you're going with your
own life I mean that's that's work
looking outside at someone else and
either judging or or just being
entertained by it that's just you know
that's that's easy right well so yeah
whats man absolutely thought you'd have
a great answer for us we want nothin um
so for being on the set and going
through the whole process with the film
what was your takeaway you know whether
it be just about family dynamics whether
it be about the discipline to follow
through on things did you have any
epiphanies that you walked away from
after
being a film well I think I think going
into the film are you talking about the
filmmaking process or the actual the
story process but really the entire
thing anything that was a takeaway it
could have been one component of it I
think the biggest thing for me because
it was it felt so different in a feature
than a short I minima and the short that
I did was short like it was seven
minutes so it was so compressed it's
just the amount of work and I mean you
know this because you're just you're
about to you know you've finished your
feel like the amount of work that goes
from the script paste you actually I
mean not Nathan lock picture to you lock
the whole thing it's just astronomical I
mean you know I think going into this
because I this was sort of the
experience on my short I kind of felt
like Oh once i got the film in the can
all the hard work was done you know and
and then it was just editing and you
know but no i mean that process it was
you know on this length of the fear on a
feature it's just so for me at least
it's so full on and so much work and so
many decisions and so many decisions
that really you know we did some test
screenings for audiences and these my
new decisions really affected you know
how the film was perceived and so it's
like having to be that like present for
every second every frame basically of
your movie to make sure it's really what
you want to say or it's the best of what
you have that you know that you can say
it was you know that was eye-opening and
i think to going into my next project I
will have that improve every moment of
everything you shoot like this so it's
just gonna maybe a heightened level of
awareness of what each moment that you
capture the act of it so I'm wondering
what you can recommend for people that
maybe they've been through a long
drawn-out process with their film and
maybe there's some inertia involved
maybe they get you know what I don't
know if I really want to face the
computer today I don't
want to deal with this today there's
frustration because I'm sure that's a
part of everybody's project things get
stuck or how do we how do we sort of
free ourselves from that inertia do we
take a break from it or do we work
through it well I'm actually both I'm a
big big proponent of what where's your
in you know where's your energy where
where is the where's its inertia coming
from is it coming from you know that you
have been stuck at the computer and not
moved and haven't been out and haven't
got an air into your system and haven't
you know I see going out and exercising
its kind of discharging your energy so
it doesn't get stuck because that really
that into it sure is thats darkness so
you know and also taking really good
care of yourself I mean you know
sleeping eating well I mean it all goes
into this process and i also feel like
if this if its inertia is not preferred
doing all that and you're still feeling
inertia I think it's really important to
go back to what drove your passion in
the first place to start to try and
remember oh ok this is this is what
really made me passionate about this
material or this story that I'm trying
to tell or this is why I want to make
you know make my first film or second
film whatever it is is why I want to do
it the first place to really tap into
that that passion ah can be really
helpful too that's great well I want to
go back to to Eileen's character in that
I understand that she clung to sort of
outdated ideas about the past and I
think even I mean all of us do I mean
that the world has changed so much in
the last four to five years and we all
sort of romanticize the past even for
filmmakers the 90s were seen as this
wonderful time you know why did Eileen
claim to this sort of outdated mode of
what her life really was well she um you
know something is revealed in the field
where she's had an experience it was you
know somewhat traumatic for her and so I
this sort of clinging to the past and
clinging to her beliefs was really about
again having something to hold onto to
not have to really feel and express
those feelings so
heard that was keeping her safe Oh
interesting and I kind of see that that
sort of clean to something that makes
you feel safe almost it could be seen as
being similar to someone that has an
addiction you know that's that's
clinging to you know the alcohol but
they know or the drug that they know or
the you know sugar I mean whatever but
it's like it's similar it's a similar
kind of reasoning or back back story
because that might be recognized yeah
man absolutely it's better work
right well you also mentioned to that
one of the biggest challenges was the
fact that you had limited time to
rehearse and and shoot the film with 19
days shooting time we've heard about
masters like you know Roger Corman being
just so efficient on set and just being
very Swift but productive how did you
keep in line with that theme of being
just very yeah I'm sure it's not easy to
do but how did you you think well yeah
and I mean a lot of a lot of them
happened I think in the script phase
where we basically cut anything that was
extraneous so everything we were
shooting we knew we had to have we
needed um but it I mean it was tough
there were days where we were going over
and I mean we had to shoot a couple of
scenes in awana because that was all
that we could do um so I don't I mean I
i hope that i was Swift I think that I
learn a lot of maybe how to do it better
next time but but I mean it was really
the constraints of how each day was set
up I mean we you know we had our scene
we had our time frame of when we had to
have that shot and we had to stick to it
so then it becomes a choice do we have
it do we have an ass there's no time to
improv you know it's like move on and
sometimes that was hard to have to make
those decisions because I love to do it
one more time you know maybe we'll get
something better maybe we'll get
something different maybe but it just
had did you get what you needed and then
it's gotta move on you know and I know
often in sort of this low-budget realm
you know one of the first things we say
about our films as it you know our film
has no stars don't recognize
talent and in your case you've attracted
an amazing talent to your project so
farm in your short film stars Jane Lynch
and Margaret child both have roles in
that film and then obviously with the
perfect family Kathleen Turner Emily
Deschanel Jason Ritter Richard
Chamberlain on and on and on what is
your process for getting these bigger
names attached to your projects well um
I think you know for me at least with
the feature um it didn't make sense to
do it unless we had someone of
Kathleen's caliber playing the lead so I
was very clear either we did it at that
budget level which was which was small
or we had to go micro budget with no
names which I didn't see how we could on
this story it was just serviced would
have been I don't know I mean I'm sure
there's a way to do it but I don't think
it would be it wouldn't be my preferred
way to try and do it so we really um you
know we had a casting director on one
board I have to say I think the first
the first step really to the whole
process and for anyone doing their first
feature is finding producers who are
more experienced than you finding
producers who can elevate this you know
this the what's the word deep how
healing it would be to be on board a
project because there's a first-time
director I mean I'm not gonna I'm not
going to attract anyone I mean perhaps
after we sat down I think if someone's
interested I could keep them interested
but they're not going to look at my name
and I have nothing to show so I bought
on producers who from prep the Cora
olson and Jennifer Dubin from present
pictures who are incredibly talented
women you know they had done two
features before I wanted premiered at
sundance of one at Toronto so which was
something that I was looking for and
producers I was looking for people who
had had films at that level because you
know I know it's all it's it's about
people knowing people it's just how how
how it works in any industry so that
felt that was important to me but could
also the fact that
a you know having their names also would
make an actor feel like all this film's
going to get my aid and it's going to
get made at a caliber that makes sense
to me so so for me bringing on those you
know our producers was the first step to
making any of it happen well let's stay
right with that thought and you know how
did you get the producers on board what
did you do to do it to attract them and
sort of get them on board with what
you're doing well um I actually was at
this lecture at film independent and it
was a producing lecture because I was
trying to at the time learn as much as I
could about producing even though I
didn't want to produce but I felt like
the more I know the better and there was
someone sitting next to me at this
lecture who was asking really really
intelligent questions like really smart
I was like who is this woman sitting
next me uncle haha sure so I ended up
talking to her and she was someone who
was a post-production supervisor but
wanting to get into producing so she
knew everything but she just was you
know they're trying to learn a bit more
about the producing side as opposed to
the post side which she was all over and
anyway so we got to talking and I talked
to her about my project and said you
know do you know um good independent
producers and she says yeah and she gave
me a few names and so I did some
research and I wasn't quite ready at
that point the script wasn't ready and
so but I kept her information and then
when this group was ready I contacted
her and said hey ah you remember those
producers you mentioned can you we put
would you be willing to put me in touch
with them and it turned out it was so
funny that she actually left the company
the post-production company she was in
and had started renting space in the
same you know office building as these
producers were in so she was seeing them
on a day-to-day basis so it was just
synchronicity perhaps but also um to
actually get the script to them I think
that was very synchronistic and then
they responded to the script and we you
know got on the phone I because in
Australia at the time so we had this big
time conversation when I was there about
you how they like to work
I like to work what we were both looking
for and we just hit it off I mean it was
amazing so let's keep with that let's
just let's just take the instance of
let's just take the instance of Kathleen
Turner you know you know we read I think
it was i think it was indiewire you know
mentioned that this is really her fur
sort of starring role in the film and
more than two decades so here you are
you have your producing team behind you
experienced how did you begin to
approach Kathleen and get her interested
in doing this film well um the the next
step pretty early on was um you know our
producers bought on casting director and
her name is Ronnie yes girl and she has
caused some big movies and she's also
cast she cast independent film as well
and my producers had worked with her
before so then I had to meet with her
and we got on so she she said yes and
Ronnie had a relationship with
Kathleen's agent so we were able to get
the script to her ah you know when we
felt like it was ready and find out that
she was interested um and then the next
step was she was interested but she
needed to talk to me so we calculate and
I got on the phone because Kathleen's in
New York and she basically told me that
she really liked the script but there
were things in it that was still missing
for her she felt like there were certain
aspects of her character that weren't
developed another one on the page an ass
and fortunately what she was saying was
totally aligned with our intention for
the script it just took her a new pair
of eyes to kind of see whether it wasn't
landing on the page and I mean she gave
some beautiful notes and they really
helped us deep in her character as well
as you know as well as the supporting
roles too but you know in that phone
conversation I made sure that it was
very clear to her that we were going to
go into a rewrite base specifically for
her based on her notes so she was
thrilled about that so it was kind of
like really listening to her and
listening to what she needed and also in
the process making sure
it's still aligned with I mean if she'd
given me notes that was so far off what
what the intention for the script was it
would never have worked but it wasn't
that it was the opposite so it made
sense for us to really try and get it
right for her man this is really such
wonderful information thank you man for
just given us some of the specs or we
want to we just want to keep pushing
this thing forward you know once once
you had the film complete or maybe even
before you had the film quickly I mean
at what point I mean did you have a do
you have a sales agent involved in the
film I mean the producers rapper there's
someone of that caliber you know helping
the sell the film did you bring ya got
on board yeah we did have a sales agent
we do have a sales agent actually still
working with us but we you know we kind
of knew it was you know with this script
in the story and that it was kind of
5050 as to whether we would actually
sell it to a distributor that we felt
like would be able to do what we wanted
to have happen with the film so we kind
of had in our back you know our idea
okay that happens that would be amazing
and that'll be great but it's incredibly
difficult um and if it doesn't we wanted
to be able to sort of bring on our own
team to distribute the film so you know
so we waited we waited to see whether
whether we could you know we could get
picked up and that didn't happen so we
decided to go for it and do it ourselves
put put a team together just kind of
like water what a you know an indie
distributable do but obviously it's on a
much smaller scale and did that happen
before after the tribe the premiere at
Tribeca it was after because we you know
we had people that were watching it and
interested but you know I just fought
for whatever reason the timing wasn't
right or just you know I didn't happen
but it was after the after the primary
in Tribeca so it's probably a couple of
months after Tribeca way we're like okay
what are we going to do we're going to
wait because some people some people
want to wait and see how the years
looking before they commit you know to
maybe a film that might give they're
unsure about but we didn't want to wait
we decided to to go for it yeah awesome
well how do you feel about the perfect
family being released in theaters and
then also on VOD at the same time well I
think um for for this film it made total
sense to do it that way because you know
we were so limited on our budget for
getting the word out there but yet
Kathleen was able to get do a ton of
international press for us so we were
able to get the word out through all the
press she was doing but we could never
reach all the cities that people would
see her on television in so we felt like
if we did this VOD it would mean that
those people would be able to access the
film right away and Kathleen I totally
got it what we were doing and so on
everything she went on she said I were
on demand you know so anyone who gets on
demand is gonna you know has access to
the film as soon as they hear her say
that as long as someone i mean i think
on demand is still something that a
portion of the population is
understanding and how to access it and
how to figure out what's on there but
some people are all over it so and then
we're also on itunes as well so there's
another whole group of people that you
know like to consume films that way so i
think you know for this budget level it
made sense but what did happen in the
process from when we first decided to do
this you know theatres and on demand at
the same time you know some of some of
the hollywood films started doing it and
the theaters started clamping down on
who they were going to allow to do this
day and day so when we started there was
a lot more theaters that we potentially
thought we could get into because they
hadn't said no but in the in the six
months of while we were sort of planning
it and starting to reach out of theater
that all changed the whole landscape
change and so we were incredibly lucky
to AMC independent was willing to work
with us in certain areas so that we
could you know get into those theaters I
think it's more the bigger cities you
know because it's the indie theaters in
in smaller cities i think the
undermanned and doesn't follow them but
some of the bigger theaters it certainly
does
and so I think that that that can be a
limiting and limiting piece too um but
yeah but I think for this film it was
definitely the right thing I mean we
don't find out for I think another month
how what happened on dammam so we're
sort of a little the jury's still out on
that but you know I think it certainly
has an effect on your theatrical numbers
because especially with a smaller film I
think people are for a lot of the time
going to want to be like I owed to stay
home and watch it I won't go out to the
theater so you know I think it does
affect those numbers but you know I mean
we're playing in theaters with these big
big movies and so you know just to
actually be on a screen is it was three
I mean I was thrilled I mean how many
how many times have you seen it on the
big screen so far um well I've probably
seen it oh I don't even know I mean I
went to quiet with in Tribeca I went to
a few of the first screen to see how the
audience would was and then a lot of the
time I I won't stay I'll just go in at
the end or something so I probably been
to like five or six with with with
audiences and then I just kind of hang
out but I did I was just the film just
played in Korea at the was in Seoul at
the Korean international women's film
festival so i sat in on that screening
because it was the first time we played
to a non-english speaking audience so
that was it was good what was the
reaction and so well well you know I did
a Q&A after after both the screens but
you were two screenings that I was there
for and they respond they loved the film
they asked really um really thoughtful
questions you know like really look
specific like why did he say this in
this line of us never quits my never
heard before I'm thinking why did he say
that let me you know I didn't it was
good but of course the comedy played
very differently I mean it wasn't like
to an english-speaking audience the
comedy didn't play the same but I felt
like as a whole the the essence
the film did the dramatic part certainly
did so it was a really good experience
and there was a girl in the audience she
was from she was from Canada living in
Canada but but was Korean and was there
and she said to me all those subtitles
were pretty accurate I was like okay
great because i had no idea if you busy
you know it's something you have cool
you know happening here is Kathleen
Turner and Jason Ritter at Emily
Deschanel on your Facebook page for the
perfect family they've been doing video
responses to some of the fans questions
we just really need to see I mean is
that something are you involved with
that directly or do you have other
people that handle that I mean are you
like sort of the one that's taping these
or how's that all happening yeah no I
was involved with the taping someone
else is helping them up for us but yeah
um we filmed you know I just went and
filmed Emily one afternoon and with
Jason did it on our press day and we
would when Kathleen I did the directors
commentary in New York and she also did
a lot of call outs for the VOD which was
which was great um we filmed her
Facebook stuff then so you know we sort
of we sort of caught them when me when
we could to do it are you handling all
the social media for the film do you
have sort of a PMD or someone that is we
walked with a publicity company brigade
they're out of New York and they handle
both the traditional publicity so all
Kathleen's PR and then also our online
our online stuff I mean we we did the
filming and things but we sort of talked
to them about what we wanted to do and
they helped you know get the questions
together and things like that so it's
kind of a combo was really you know
working with with a team as opposed to
having someone else do it for you and
we're also not doing it all ourselves so
it's sort of collaborate yeah that's
nice well now the film's premiered at
one of the top festivals and it's been
given a theatrical and is currently
available everywhere have you reached
all of your goals for the film or are
there other sort of levels that you want
to top or avenues you want to take well
um
I think I think we've reached a lot of
goals we're still working on our forum
and we've had so many people reaching
out to us on Facebook and you know and
me on Twitter as well you know asking
about foreign we're still trying to
figure out that because we were we did
have a sales company that we're going to
go with the foreign but there were just
some things we couldn't agree on in the
contract that felt like it was going to
make sense for us and not put us in
financial potential financial you know
problems down the track if it didn't you
know go down the way it was said it
would go down so we didn't sign with a
foreign sales agent and we're sort of
piecing together our foreign and
figuring it out as we go and you know
when I say we'd probably my producers
and either my producers are very very
savvy and very very quick so there you
know we're getting figuring out this
landscape as quick as we can but I
really hope that it's quick enough to
get it out into the place since that it
makes sense ah but you know financially
as well as people being able to see it
yeah what did you learn from working
with Kathleen Turner I mean aside from
being such an amazing actor she's a
force of nature when you would see her
in a Q&A I mean she just she had the
room you know what was it that I mean
were there any takeaways where you kind
of went haha just something any type of
lesson that you learned from watching
her you know I think the biggest thing
is duck hold back because she would just
get into an interview I mean I learned I
did I learnt so much particularly in the
interview stage after I mean I learned a
lot on set but I expected to learn a lot
but you know I wasn't didn't really have
it in my periphery what what it was
gonna happen with the press but she just
gets in there and she's so engaged and
she's so expressive and she doesn't pull
back like her thoughts or you know and
and I love that I I respect that in
someone instead they can just you know
and I mean she's kind like she's never
going to she doesn't you know whoever
intention is never input whatever she's
saying to harm or anything
but I mean it's a good lesson because I
think it's easier to to you know when
you're on camera especially especially
for me to kind of feel like all you know
maybe I shouldn't even say that or you
know I guess it's at keeping up
appearances thing which I I don't think
I do with people I know or anything like
that but then when you're going out on a
larger scale and the whole you know who
knows who's gonna see it I think it can
be you know I'm more of a tendency to be
like oh let me say this right or let me
express this right so again I think
maybe part of the human condition but
something that I certainly want to work
on just being out or really speak so she
lets go without without being you know
harmful like you said but she's able to
just kind of let go and just be who she
is yeah absolutely that's great you know
one absolute delight and having a having
this opportunity to sit down and speak
with you um it's really nice you
provided us just just tremendous insight
you know and and I believe you give hope
and inspiration to all female directors
male directors out there Wow I think we
all would like to sort of model
ourselves off some of the things that
that you shared here oh that's really
great yeah very kind thank you i want to
thank you both for your show i didn't
get to say but like winners in the prep
phase for the film and very early as i'm
working on this script it's I'm like
going walking on the beach and I have my
headphones on it up listening to you
during your interviews on my cupcake you
know whenever someone saying something
positive like what you're saying it's
like okay yeah I can do it I can do it
so your show is very inspirational and I
think really such an important thing
filmmakers to be able to have access to
listen to other people's experiences and
journeys with their project and and I
know how much work you know the sugar
has been as well as you doing your other
your other life stuff in your film I
mean it's incredible the amount of time
you've given so thank you thank you
thank you thank you thank you mama here
we've been speaking with filmmaker and
renton um you know you can find out more
about her oh I actually connect with her
directly on twitter at certainty films
certain see films
and you can also connect and find out
more about the perfect family the
perfect family movie calm as well as on
facebook at the perfect family and how
long will we continue to see the film in
theaters and how long will the
contenders continue to see it on VOD
well as the apps you can run yeah we did
a short theatrical run we're still in
some theaters we're in a theater in
Florida that's doing really really well
and there's a couple of cities that
we're we're we're in and so probably
another few weeks in you know certain
locations but we're on demand and so
anyone who has cable and go on demand
and get it or an itunes or on itunes as
well so and then we have the DVD that
comes out jun 26 oh very nice
congratulations in well I'm graduations
that's awesome thank you thank you for
having me on the show oh yeah thank you